العوده من اكثر المسلسلات اللي كانت
منتظره هذا الموسم الدرامي فهو يشكل عوده
لعمل تربى عليه اجيال على مدار سنوات ناقش
خلالهم مختلف قضايا المجتمع السعودي في
اطار كوميدي وصار جزء لا يتجزء من ذاكره
السعوديين وحتى العرب ورجع لهم هذا رمضان
بعد انقطاع 12 سنه العمل من بطوله النجمين
عبد الله السدحان وناصر القصبي اللي شكلوا
ثنائيه ولامسوا بادائهم وجدان وقلب كل
محبينهم وفي عشرين حلقه رجعولنا مع طاقم
المسلسل او رجعوا لنا مع طاقم المسلسل
الكثير من الذكريات والحنين وقدموا عمل
حصد ارشادات وواسعه
اما بالنسبه لي البسمه اللي تركها طاش
العوده عند المتابعين فيمكننا عنونها
بالحنين والذكريات وهذه عينه من تعليقات
الناس على المسلسل وحلقاته
ومن الرياض معنا النجم عبد الله السدحان
اهلا فيك معانا وكل عام وانت بالف خير يا
رب
اهلا وسهلا وكل عام وانتم جميعا بالف خير
لمن يعني نقدر نطالع بعد ما انتهت الحلقات
وانتهى العرض وشفنا الردود الفعل وشفنا
الحلقات وشفنا كيف كل شيء كيف عبد الله
السدحان اليوم يقيم طاش العوده
حقيقه التقييم ما هو عندي هو عند المتلقي
هو من القيم اذا انا بقيم فبعطي انفسنا
درجات اقل حقيقه
كنا بحاجه الى تايمنج او وقت بالاصح
اكيد انه العوده بعد توقف دائما من 11 او
12 سنه لابد ان يكون في بعض التردد بعض
التخوف من جميع الجوانب يعني سواء انا او
القائمين على العمل او زميلي وصديقي
وحبيبي ابو راكان نفس الشيء يعني كان
عندنا نوع من التوجس لكن بعد انتهاء العمل
لكن هي النقطه الوحيده اللي انا اقدر
اقولها عن طاش ما طاش وتقييم له بغض النظر
عن نجاح حلقه من ضعف حلقه او بالاصح يعني
من متوسط الى جيد الى جيد جدا وما شابه
طاش ما طاش يبقى هو
عمل يلم الاسره همم هذا من خلال ملاحظتي
لكثير من المنازل والبيوت يعني هو العمل
الذي استطاع ان يلم الاسره جميع الصغير
والكبير والوسط وهكذا فهذه ميزه تسجل الى
عمل تحت مسمى طاش
من اجابتك يعني خليتني عندي كذا سؤال بدي
اسالك هو اول شيء حضرتك ذكرت قلت انه
صديقي وحبيبي ابو راكان يعني عوده التعاون
مع ناصر القصبي بعد 12 سنه كان كيف كانت
الكواليس بعد هذا
الغياب يعني خصوصا انه في فتره كانت فيها
اخذ ورد وقيل وقالوا خلافات يعني
في خلافات هي خلافات في وجهات نظر على
الانتاج والعمل والشراكه وما شابه وهذه
تحصل في كثير من الشركات من
شركات كبرى بنوك وما شابه هي خلافات بسيطه
وفي مرحله عمريه معينه هذه منتهيه لكن بعد
العوده
حقيقه يعني كاننا امس يعني كان 11 سنه
اختزلت في فتره سبع شهور او ثمانيه شهور
ما حسينا باي شيء يعني يبقى هو عرفني وانا
اعرفه يعني احنا عارفين بعض
وهدفنا في النهايه ان هذه السفينه ان تصل
الى الى المرفا او تصل الى بر الامان بشكل
مناسب وجيد
بعض الناس حضرتك زي ما ذكرت قلت انه يعني
انه جيده جدا جيد كل هذا الكلام انه في
تفاوت في الحلقات بعض الناس هذا كان
تعليقها الاساسي انه في تفاوت في مستوى
الحلقات فانت بتتفق يعني مع هذا الموضوع
هل بتعتقد انه هذا شيء يعني عادي او انه
كان كده في السابق ولا في مشكله يعني
نعم نعم في عادي جدا بالعكس في السابق
اجزاءنا 18 17 16 نزولا
لو حسبنا نكتشف ان هناك خمسه او ست حلقات
متميزه جدا
والاخرى جيد وهكذا في هذا الجزء قد يكون
الجيد جدا اكثر من النسبه اللي كانت
موجوده في الاجزاء السابقه حقيقه يعني لكن
هو ضيق الوقت يعني حقيقه انا اقدر اقول
عنه طاش العوده مثل الكويز الاختبار
المفاجئ او الامتحان المفاجي في قاعه
الامتحانات او في قاعه الكليه او الجامعه
لما الدكتور يقول لك
طلعوا ورق واكتب عندك امتحان الان اختبار
سؤال مفاجي مهما كان امامنا وقت لكتابه
النصوص او ورش لكن
لا نستبعد النفسيه الحاله السيك لكل شخص
فينا سواء قال لي اقصد المشاركين في ورشه
النص
من هو جديد على هذه الورشه ومن هو من
اعتاد على هذه الورشه اضافه الى انه
ينظرون نظره اخرى انه عبد الله وناصر كيف
يعني كان هذا الشغل الشاغل لكن ابو راكان
وعبد الله اكبر من هذه الامور
مرحله متجاوزه وتم تجاوزها بكل اريحيه
وبكل بساطه بس ما تحس انه يعني بعد هذه
الخبره كلها انكم لازم تطمحوا انه الحلقات
تكون كلها ممتازه
على الشاشه يعني يعتبر الموضوع انتهاك
الحق والادبي والفكري وانه صاحب حق بحكم
من محكمه الاستئناف الاداريه بمنطقه
الرياض وانه انتم ما كان فيكم تستخدموا
كلمه طاش مره اخرى في العنوان كيف بترد
على هذا الكلام
اولا لا تعليق بني مطول في التعليق هذا
اخذنا ولدتين وعجلنا في جهات معينه هي ترى
هذا الموضوع الى هل راي ثانيا انا وبركان
لا نتعدى كنا في هذا الجزء ممثلين يعني
مقابل اجر معين نقدم عمل مشتاق لهالمشاهد
فهذه قضيه ما تهمني انا ولا يهمني
القرقعه الكلام وكثر الحكي يعني مو موضوعي
وهم المشاهد
بقدر ما احنا نضيع في وقت
مو موضوع جدلي خلينا نقول انه لما انكتب
التغريده صار عليه جدال بس طيب خلاص وصلت
رسالتك لهذا الموضوع خليني كمان يعني اعرض
لك تغريده ثانيه للناقد رجل سير المطيري
كان بيقول فيها انه طاش المشروع يجب ان
يستمر انه مهما كان مستواه ولازم يتحول
لزي اللي مستمر صار له خمسين سنه وناجح
جدا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وطبعا
حول العالم ايضا هل ممكن نتوقع انه في جزء
ثاني ويستمر هذا المشروع
العلم عند الشيوخ حقيقه يعني هم من جمعنا
وهم من
اسسوا طاش العوده وهذا الفكره
العلم عند ابو ناصر تحديدا يعني انا اتوقع
ابو ناصر
و الشيخ ابراهيم
وانا قلت ما فيه نعم يعطيهم الصحه
والعافيه انا واثق انهم بدلوا قصاره جهدهم
وليست القضيه هي ماليه بقدر ما هي حتى
نفسيه لانه
توقف 11 سنه واعاده عمل ويلقى ردود فعل
متباينه وجميله شيء يعتبر انجاز لهم الشكر
حقيقه معالي المستشار ابو ناصر تركي علي
الشيخ الشيخ وليد الابراهيم
حقيقه لهم دور فعال وهم اعتبرهم الابطال
خلف الكواليس لكن لما نرجع الى
عطاش على تغريدة أخي والاستاذ رجاء
انا قلت في بدايه اللقاء انه طاش هو اصبح
جزء من الموروث الشعبي السعودي لا اتوقع
انه عبد الله السد او ناصر القصبي في هذه
المرحله او بهذا العمر بحاجه الى شهره او
اضواء او ما شابه لا احنا المهم عندنا
كفنانين صادقين برساله لنحملها هو ارضاء
المتلقي وحقيقه انا يهمني لم الاسره انا
لست ضد الاعمال الاخرى بالعكس انا اشجع
على ان يكون هناك اعمال اخرى سواء قبل طاش
او 14 او ما يكون في طاش وكانت فيه 11 سنه
منحت هذه فرصه للجميع لاثبات وجودهم وظهر
ممثلين رائعين واسماء جميله سواء من
الجنسين حقيقه لكن لما نتكلم انا من وجهه
نظري انه اصبح طاش موروث شعبي موروث سعودي
الجميع يشاهده من المغرب العربي الى
الخليج اذا ما دخلنا في بعض الدول الاخرى
فهو جزء لا يتجزا من الحياه يعني انا لا
انسى اتصالات زمان يقول ما كنا نعرف عن
السعوديه الا مكه لكن من خلال طاش عرفنا
البيت السعودي والاسره السعوديه والمجتمع
السعودي الحقيقي وهذا شيء يعني نفتخر فيه
حقيقه
كمان يمكن واحده من اكثر الحلقه كفيت ولا
تبيني اكمل لا يعني انت وفيت وفيت بس انه
ما اعطتني اجابه واضحه انه اذا بتتكلموا
على جزء ثاني ولا لا الصراحه هل ناقشوكم
طيب
ما تكلمنا حقيقه
لا لا لكن انا مثل ما تفضلت أنا
همي هو المتلقي همي هي الاسره يعني طاش
مثل ولا بدي
التان لو جو
شيوخ لو قالوا لك الشيوخ تعال في نشتغل
على جزء ثاني السنه الجايه حتقول اوكي
اكيد اني لا يمكن بقول لهم انتم فصلوا
وانا البس لكن حيكون لي بعض الشروط
البسيطه اللي هي في النص لابد ان يكون لنا
ورشه النص يكون لنا الدور فيها رئيسي ومهم
بركان لانه في ورشه النصف في الاعمال
السابقه من طاش ما طاش او
كلنا عيال قريه كنا رئيسيين في ورشه النص
ونخيط ودائما الثنائيات جميله يعني انا من
خلال ردود الفعل اللي انا سمعت عن طاش
العوده انه الحلقات اللي فيها ثنائيات
كانت هي الجميله حقيقه لانه في تناغم كبير
اللي فيها الحنين اعرفوا وهو يعرف وش انا
ما بغض النظر عن الحنين لا احنا عارفين
بعض يعني
صح ايوه
بس انا كنت حابه
يمكن واحده عملت صدى مره كبيره للحلقه
اللي تكلمتوا فيها عن المخدرات اللي حتى
وزير الاعلام سلمان الدوسري ايضا غرد اعنه
شايفين الان تغريدته على الشاشه ومدحها
بشكل كبير وهي لاقت استحسان كبير من الناس
هذه الحلقه تحديدا انتم كنتم مهتمين فعلا
انكم توصلوا فيها هذه الرساله تحديدا يعني
صحيح مهم جدا وهذا لا تنسين اني انا قبل
اسره ولله الحمد
وكذلك اعتبر كل شباب هذا الوطن ابنائي
حقيقه من الجنسين فهذه الافهة
وخواتها يعني حقيقه شيء مدمر يعني وانا
حنا قاعدين نسمع ونقرا ونشوف
نتائجها فيجب ان تتضافر الجهود اكثر واكثر
للتوعيه لكن بطريقه غير مباشره بطريقه
تداعب المشاعر هذا اللي انا اقصد طيب نحن
شاكرين لك في ظهورك معنا اليوم وطبعا الف
مبروك
العمل والف مبروك هذه العوده وشكرا انك
خصصت لنا هذا الوقت وكل عام وانت بالف خير
كان معنا طبعا من الرياض النجم الكبير عبد
الله السدحان شكرا لك